[Music]
how do we decipher the thousands of
studies that are out there on all of
these diets and the problem is what
people will do to try to sell you a
false bill of goods is take one study
and blow that study out as though it's
the entire picture when of course it
isn't
imagine you have a massive painting but
I only showed you this tiny piece of the
painting but you had no idea what the
hell else was going on over here there's
no way you could get an accurate read on
if this is a sad picture a happy picture
a danger like there's no way you could
know correct so when we look at Quito
here's why we're saying or not me but
here's where some of the advocates are
espousing benefits well what are we
doing with Quito right we're removing
carbohydrates anything that elevates
you've got about 20 grams of
carbohydrates a day that you're
ingesting which is essentially nothing
it's about 80 calories worth of
carbohydrates out of what could be
anywhere from a 1600 to 2500 calorie a
day diet so that's nothing right and it
throws your body into a state of
emergency that's what ketosis is and
because we don't have any glucose or
glycogen any blood sugar stored blood
sugar we turn to fat quickly we produce
ketones and the ideas we've burned
through fat and we lose fat fast and
that is true right and you would think
that would be a good thing and in
addition people will say well I reversed
my type-2 diabetes
of course you know your insulin level is
through the floor you're consuming zero
carbohydrates so you have no blood sugar
so your pancreas is not releasing
insulin and this can also affect
conditions like polycystic ovarian
syndrome and you know by virtue of that
connection you could also affect
fertility there let's give it that but
here's what we're not talking about
there's zero calorie restriction on a
ketogenic diet so you have a massive
amount of oxidative stress there's no
consideration of timing with regard to
food so you're a toff adji process is
totally out of whack in addition to that
it's very high in animal fats and animal
proteins so we're seeing
the diets rich in saturated fats are
poor for our telomeres oxidative stress
increased inflammation your nutrient
sensing pathways that are related to the
health of your metabolism are overrun
with constant food heavy fats lots of
animal protein and ah we know it hurts
your telomeres and on and on and on now
what about the benefits is it worth it
let me tell you the number one way to
sensitize somebody's body again to
insulin is exercise I've been doing this
a heck of a long time i reversed type 2
diabetes I have helped people get off
all medications for type 2 diabetes and
PCOS and get pregnant after years of
trying and failing through a common
sense diet where we don't eat too much
we eat real food and we have balanced
macronutrients so I can give you all
those benefits with none of the negative
side effects of keto and last thought on
keto we're stripping or a body of
certain fruits which have a ton of
antioxidants and polyphenols in them so
again when we look at oxidative stress
and free radicals and how they're aging
us we need to look at antioxidant foods
that help to combat that when you start
cutting out digestive enzymes in papaya
and pineapple and mango and all of the
beta-carotene which is one of the top
things to help keep your telomeres long
something like keto is detrimental on so
many different levels and the amount of
benefit is so small when we could take a
completely different path get all the
benefit over here none of the negatives
over here and all the benefits over
there
[Music]